[Musik]
wir hoffen auf regen und sturm sehr nah
beieinander während draußen die
domplatte zwar schon abgesperrt ist aber
es waren über wind
die polizisten
da draußen tun ist er drin
ganz schön angespannt weil es fährt gar
nicht gerade kann man zum
sicherheitsbeamten und fragt nach
amsterdam kommt dann sagt der
sicherheitsmann amsterdam grund so
laufen oder rad also selbst die
sicherheitsleute sind schon einigermaßen
angespannt
mita deutschland tradition stellen sich
die leute hier ins lang an an schildern
steht muss nach köln oder das kurze
aber im moment hätte gar nicht
[Musik]
in hamburg
die lage am morgen beruhigt ich stehe
jetzt hier gerade am hamburger
fischmarkt und es könnte durchaus sein
dass das wasser der elbe hier im laufe
des tages noch über die ufer tritt ist
noch eine sturm angesagt aber insgesamt
muss man sagen ist hamburg relativ
glimpflich davon gekommen
die feuerwehr ist über 300 einsätzen
ausgerückt in blankenese ist ein
house von einer herabstürzenden kastanie
zerstört worden und die köhlbrandbrücke
eine wichtige verkehrsader für den
hamburger hafen die ist zeitweise in der
nacht gesperrt gewesen
aber man muss sagen die hamburger die
sind einfach auch stürme gewöhnt und
nicht umsonst heißt es hier oben sturm
ist erst wenn die schafe keine locken
mehr haben